recently I created a video that
discussed my interpretation of a quiet
place I hypothesized that the monsters
in the film represented censorship and
how people in the modern age were
acquired more and more to not speak out
on certain opinions that they had in
fear of the backlash that they could
face this related to social media work
politics celebrity and more I really
wanted to open up a conversation and my
theory could be interpreted in any way
that you see fit it's currently my
highest viewed video and I was very
happy with the response of people some
disagree completely others believe that
I was correct and a lot and a lot of
people thought I was wrong and that the
monsters were just monsters it was a
great discussion and I highly recommend
that you go and check out the video
which will be linked in the description
at the end of this one I was very lucky
that a close friend of mine Pamela who
works at uni lad was interviewing John
Krasinski the film's director and star
and brought up the theory with him in
order to get his thoughts on it what
follows is a small segment of their
interview which offers up Krasinski's
thoughts on fan theories of the film
including mine Oh interesting
because he felt like you know you can
get into a point in time where you can't
speak out as much anymore because
everyone comes around to I think it's
awesome somebody brought that up and
there's another interview I was talking
about and I think that's I mean there's
no better compliment to any movie that
it starts a conversation so I love that
people have their own ideas about this
that's great it's brilliant that
Krasinski responded and I sort of fanboy
dab it over this clip especially because
I think the film is incredible a quiet
place definitely has a lot of thematic
things that can be taken from it and I
highly recommend that you check out the
film in theaters it offers an experience
like no other where silence is demanded
from beginning to end
and its atmosphere is near unrivaled I'd
like to give a huge shout out to Bama
lamb at uni lad film for putting this
theory in front of John and if you want
to see the entire interview you can
check out their Facebook page linked in
the description they post exclusive
interviews News and Easter Egg videos
weekly and it's definitely worth
checking out if you're a fan of film I'd
also like to thank Paramount for
allowing us to use this footage from the
interview and allowing me to discuss the
film in greater depth with more ending
explain videos and film fan theories
please subscribe to my channel if you
like this video and want to see more
than you can check out my full analysis
of a quiet place on my channel thanks
very much for taking the time to watch
this video take care peace